good morning and welcome to ask doc live
sponsored by askdoclive.com
we are very happy to see you here
my name is ruth ellen sanchez and i am
hosting today's show while rebecca
our regular host is traveling
so it's nice to see everybody
and um
i just want to remind everyone that this
program is meant for
educational purposes only
and the information is just
meant to help you
have knowledge on your health and
well-being
i would like to introduce dr joel
wallach
who is our
uh guest
our speaker always um so ask doc live
we'll start now with dr wallach
well thank you ruth ellen and welcome to
everybody
um let's see here basically we have a
lot of new people here so i'm going to
just give it just a couple of minutes
now what makes me different is that i'm
a veterinarian as well as a physician a
naturopathic physician i have three
post-doctoral fellowships one of which
was from nih at 25 million dollars
washington university center for biology
of natural systems i did 20 000
autopsies my thesis
5 000 pages is in the smithsonian
institute as a national treasure very
very proud of that because they showed
in those 20 000 autopsy 17 000 some
change
of over 454 species of zoo animals and
humans uh 3 000 autopsies now and what i
showed was there are no jaguar
transmitter diseases there are no
autoimmune translated diseases okay
these are all nutritional deficiencies
and doctors didn't know about that so
they just kind of came up well your
body's making a mistake and that's why
you have these diseases no it's
nutritional deficiencies so we're
responsible for taking in these
these essential
factors i don't like to call them
supplements because they're not a choice
okay they are required 60 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 minutes to 3 fatty acids
to give you maximum lifespan and maximum
health
we suffer from things all over the world
because people make the same mistakes
they choose to eat certain ways and
don't make sure they're getting
everything you have to appreciate in
1936 the u.s senate came out with u.s
senate documents 264 and they said
there's no longer enough nutrition
in our soils
to maximize
life and health in america okay those
1936 u.s senate document 264.
so
um
we have programs
for over 600 different diseases we have
5 000 products there's bound to be one
or two you'd like
we can prevent and reverse heart disease
we can prevent and reverse
let's see here
diabetes type 2 diabetes we can prevent
type 1 diabetes but we prevent and
reverse type 2 diabetes we can prevent
and reverse high hybrid pressure we can
prevent reverse arthritis osteoporosis
and kidney failure with dialysis i take
people that haven't urinated in 10 years
they're on dialysis six days a week and
in two weeks time on our program they're
urinating and two more weights are
totally off of dialysis
and so um these things are
we've been doing this for over 50 years
and of course as my thesis is in the
smithsonian institute
um
let's see here
we also because of bruce willis getting
aphasia which is kind of a variation on
alzheimer's disease there's all kinds of
other things hunting disease parkinson's
disease and so forth these
brain diseases
are all caused by nutritional
deficiencies okay and they're easily
prevented and easily reversed okay i
take people
who have had huntington's disease which
is kind of a um
hunting disease is parkinson's disease
all the tremors and everything
and you've got fibromyalgia and
brain problems including alzheimer's
disease and aphasia it's all called
hunting disease and i've had people who
have been seeing doctors for 20 years
and just slowly getting worse and in my
program in two weeks it went away
okay and so this is i have so much
history this is unimpeachable evidence
and then
we also have
the issue of gender issues
which start
years before
the conception of a child
people don't start when they're 18 years
old and say well i know i'm a biological
boy but i want to be a girl no that's
not how it works
the hypothalamus which is a part of the
brain in the middle part of the brain
um and the pituitary gland and your
adrenal glands determine who you're
gonna chase for sex and who you're gonna
allow to chase you for sex okay
now when these um tissues are forming in
the embryo in the first weeks of
pregnancy
if mama's missing something
there's a hick up there and you know
it's kind of like you're supposed to
have 10 fingers including a thumb on
each hand
five fingers and a thumb on each hand
two arms two hands ten fingers and a
thumb on each hand
but if you're missing stuff you can be
born with one finger or no fingers okay
the same principle is true with the
hypothalamus and the
and the um pituitary and the adrenal
glands so we can we can end all this
stuff
with the gender issues by making sure
that when we give these health classes
to kids in 12th grade instead of talking
about getting surgery you know when you
have a gender issue
we want to talk about how to prevent the
gender issues okay
and what we need to do is make sure
that all these
people are getting the 90th century
nutrients 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
minutes to 3 fatty acids they're eating
eggs with soft yolks because
our hormones
are 95 by weight cholesterol your brain
is 75 by weight cholesterol you cannot
be on statin drugs
because they all contribute to the
appearance of these gender issues okay
and so this is all totally preventable
it shouldn't be a political issue
because it's a
nutritional deficiency issue which is
preventable and we have
of course our hgh human growth hormone
uh which i like
young people to take even for themselves
as well as for future babies
uh we also have zero tests for males and
zero
femme from females uh and i'm working on
people who have gender issues and
they're teenagers or pre-teenagers you
know they may be six seven eight ten
years old
and they say mommy i know i'm a boy but
i want to be a girl mommy i know i'm a
girl i want to be a boy well these are
ones you want to get on two or three
eggs twice a day with soft yolks get
that cholesterol in the brain and then
you want to get them on the uh hgh the
human growth hormone two or three of
those twice a day you want to get them
on the zera femme for biological girls
is there a test for biological boys okay
and there's some that are already in
trouble with gender issues that we can
reverse okay if they're mildly
affected
we can reverse them okay
and so it's best to prevent them
okay and it's um not that we you know
what can i say when a little when a
little girl is two years old and said
mommy i want to be a boy
a little boy say mommy i want to be a
girl
you have to jump on that and get them on
the appropriate supplements right then
in the in the diet right then get them
off of gluten so they can absorb stuff
and we won't have the gender issue to
deal with anymore
okay
and so with all that said
the simple ones heart disease diabetes
high blood pressure arthritis
osteoporosis that kind of stuff kidney
failure dialysis liver cirrhosis fatty
liver
um
as you can see here um
the the
heart diseases there's about 18
different heart diseases they're just
simple nutritional deficiencies
okay
and so we need to make sure that
everybody's on the 90th century
nutrients these are not supplements i
hate the word supplements because that
means it's a choice
no these are
essential factors these are 90 essential
factors
just like in your car you don't put dirt
from texas or saudi arabia in your oil
pan and hope there's oil in it you don't
put all dirt from texas or saudi arabia
in your gas tank and hope there's
gasoline in it
you put gasoline in the tank and you put
oil in the oil pan
okay
and you put
antifreeze in the radiator even
summertime because that helps keep the
radiator fluid
in the proper temperature range you
check the air pressure in your tires and
so you need to be doing the same thing
for yourself well i don't know how to to
tell if i have diabetes well that's why
we have the books let's play doctor
let's be herbal doctor passport roman
therapy it's all in your head covers 600
different diseases in those four books
and gives you things you can do
in your home to prevent them and reverse
them
we have
a new
this just came out this is a new updated
version of our
what okay our books and tapes and cds
and things
it's the education brochure i guess we
call it okay and it has a cover pictures
i thought i had like 17 books but
account i counted them on on this
brochure i have 21 books okay i actually
have 22 but the 22 the 22nd one the big
one and it's in the smithsonian
institute they sell for 25 000 so
there's no sense to put it on here
because nobody's going to spend 25 000
for a health book for their family
okay but we did come out
uh with the book called epigenetics
which replaces
uh that book uh that's in the
smithsonian institute for the average
person okay and it only costs 20
something bucks and if you buy 10 of
them
um for either sale or for giving to your
family and friends and associates and so
forth workmates and church mates and
pastors and rabbis so on uh we'll give
you ten for well
it's anywhere from between an eight and
ten dollar discount
okay on each book if you buy ten or more
okay so we wanna get this information
out there the newest book
is
uh there's a book in a cd and a dvd set
and this was
instigated by jimmy osmond the younger
brother of donnie and marie
okay
and he said doc you know
it's 20 years since you published
dead doctors don't lie the book and the
cd
why don't you come up with a
a um an updated version so we did and
it's called the truth about nutrition
and it's a book in the cd and dvd we
don't sell the cd the dvd or the book
separately they only sell them as a set
but again if you buy 10 of these we'll
take 10 off of each set
and so you will
save 100 bucks when you buy 10 of these
and if you sell two or three of them at
the regular price you'll make a profit
of you know of 10 bucks on each sale
okay and so
it's one of those things that um
i get excited about it because we're
gonna get the information out there and
then also those four books let's play
doctor let's play herbal doctor passport
chrome therapy it's all in your head
it's all in your head covers 25
different diseases that doctors just
don't pay attention to uh you go to them
and you have loose teeth and receding
gums and bleeding dumbs they send you to
their classmates who became a dentist
okay
i if you have things going on
um with you ringing your ears that sort
of stuff he sent you to his brother
who's at your nose and throat doctor
okay
and so what you want to do is read this
book because all of those issues are
nutritional deficiencies they're going
to give you pharmaceuticals they're
going to give you drugs to reduce the
symptoms you're going to be happy
because the pain goes away
the ring in your ears goes away your
balance problems go away okay you'll see
better you can't regain your sense of
smell uh your bell's palsy will go away
your pain in your face will go away
because you had trigeminal neuralgia
okay that kind of stuff
but
you're gonna you're gonna be under
medication forever well you get this
book it's all in your head and there's a
formula in there
to deal with osteoporosis of the skull
osteoporosis of the skull causes 25
different diseases
including herbs palsy where the baby's
born and it was inability to walk or use
their arms or anything like that doctors
oh they have cerebral palsy no they had
herbs palsy which is obviously a process
of skull squeezing the spinal cord and
you can get that baby on her kids toddy
and the cherrymans and the efas and in
weeks time
they'll be moving their arms and legs
like they're supposed to just in weeks
after they're born
and this is all simple stuff i've been
doing this for over 50 years
okay
and i have to tell you i've been doing
this uh for myself personally
um since 19
1997. is that correct wow
1997. it's 75 years any rate 1975 years
have been doing this okay
now it's got to be longer than that
it's um
1947. there you go 1947.
1775 years okay
i've been doing this and so for myself
personally and i just want you to
understand that you can get the same
benefit this is not difficult this is
very easy
it's uh again the recipes are all in
these books
the products are available at wholesale
prices you i will pay the shipping if
you get on auto ship
and there's a new um uh report out which
we're gonna publish not publish it but
print it out and and talk about that
maybe next week but basically all the
industrialized nations have lost
anywhere from five to ten years in
average life expectancy
since
mid-1990s okay so 1990
1985 okay
um
we have lost about five to ten years of
average lifespan okay life expectancy
and that's very very scary stuff that's
because our food is getting less and
less and less
equipped with the nutrition
and people come up with weird diets i
love it when people say oh i'm dairy
free why are you dairy free well because
i didn't want to have the fat i didn't
want to have the cholesterol and dairy
well what's the first food that the good
lord made for every mammal including
human being whales and giraffes and
human beings and lions and tigers and
bears
elephants
wombats kangaroos
every mammal rats rabbits
possums raccoons
uh every mammal what's their first
food for the babies ruse ellen
yes mother's milk well they're milk
would you look at that milk is not a bad
thing
but if you're going to go dairy free and
also
who were all the
the angels that followed moses who are
all the angels who followed jesus okay
they were all
herdsmen and dairy men
some of them were fishermen
okay these are all simple people who
ate what the good lord put on earth for
us to eat
including dairy and cheese and so on
and you just want to avoid
chemicals like sprays and things like
that so if you get range fed
uh um beef that's fine if you get range
fed dairy that's fine you get range fed
eggs that's fine
okay our guaranteed chemical free
and so on you can't go without those
foods because that's why we're having
this loss of life expectancy people are
giving up the good foods because they
have some weird ideas
and um
again we have over five thousand
products and i just get excited about
the story
of why we're in trouble uh was because
we went from wood stoves to electric
stoves at three o'clock in the afternoon
monday september fourth eighteen eighty
two when thomas assessed and pulled the
switch on the first commercial electric
generating plant
and nobody said well we've got to make
up the difference because we're not
putting wood ashes which were minerals
that the tree had sucked up out of the
ground we're not putting wood ashes into
our gardens anymore as fertilizer we're
not putting wood ashes in our food
anymore we didn't have
electricity on our farm until i was nine
years old we didn't have telephones we
didn't have uh radio we didn't have tv
we didn't have any of that stuff
and so um we sat and talked to each
other which was a great thing but now
we're in trouble
because this book and the cd comes out
and
it's called again hell's kitchen and it
goes into the story of how electricity
has killed more people
than all the wars that in the history of
the earth
okay because it shut off our flow
of essential
factors
not our supplements they're not
supplements they're not a choice
oxygen is not a supplement water is not
a supplement these 90 essential
nutrients are not supplements they are
essential
nutrients remember using the document
264 came out in 1936 that american
farm cells no longer have enough
nutrition in them to support healthy
life
that's the u.s senate and you know these
are mixtures of people backgrounds and
so forth and they came out and said in
1936 and it's only gotten worse
and so
with that i'm going to turn it over to
ruth ellen and we can start uh
moving forward today
well again i want to welcome everyone
who joined us while doc was talking
welcome to astock live my name is ruth
ellen sanchez and i'm helping doc host
the um
zoom today the zoom show
and i also want to remind everybody that
if you would like to ask a question um
down below on the lower portion of your
screen is a tab called reactions and if
you click on it you should be able to
see a thing that says
raise your hand and if it's not there
and you have an older version of zoom it
may be under participants we would love
to take your questions and look forward
to helping you
um
so jack
i know that um
when we had all the dams go up that also
affected our minerals in the water
because it eliminated the silt from
going through the farmland and and um
i'm a little nervous
in floods and different things and
now the flood plains used to be
the the farm soil of choice people would
work hard to buy farms okay that would
flood every year and then when the water
would reseed they'd plow all those
minerals and silt back into the soil and
so the soil had a stable
source of minerals every year
well as you point out when we when we
dammed up the rivers for flood control
we dammed up the rivers for irrigation
we dammed up the rivers later on for
electricity
okay hydroelectric
and um
we cut off those that food supply we cut
off that silt
to the
um
farm soils well the same thing has
happened
okay
uh the same thing had happened
uh
good doc can you still hear me yes we
can hear and see you now
okay we just couldn't see you for a
minute okay um and so the same thing is
happening in the dead zones and also in
the reefs the reefs aren't being killed
by
pollution they're being killed by
hypoxia lack of oxygen because
people aren't getting the truth about
photosynthesis photosynthesis requires
sunlight okay everybody knows that
photosynthesis requires
let's see here chlorophyll everybody
knows that
but they think that's it no
the chloroplast the little things little
bags inside green plants that have the
chlorophyll in them require 20 different
nutrients
to perform photosynthesis so if you have
sunlight and chlorophyll
but only three of those 20 nutrients
you're not going to get much going on
there and so we have dead zones in the
oceans and gulfs and bays
and so forth and swamps
because
there's not enough of those nutrients
for photosynthesis to take place and
many of these
creatures that maintain build and
maintain reefs
are
oxygen requiring polyps okay
and so the reefs are dying for the same
reason they're dying of hypoxia the
um 300 million years ago i take that
back 500 million years ago and i take
that back
over
a billion years ago
the 25 000 species of trilobites
died from hypoxia because glaciers came
along and shut off the food supply
to the to the marine life
uh and they didn't have oxygen and they
died and then
it went like
a hundred thousand years
and then we got dinosaurs and the last
dinosaur died 66 million years ago and
they died of hypoxia they didn't
and hippies say oh they died of
pollution there was no people back then
there were no cars back
66 million years ago driving around on
the highways
that's nonsense
okay and so um uh
the
1 200 species of dinosaurs died out
okay then we got the dead zones then we
got the the reefs are dying and
everybody keeps blaming pollution no no
no
okay
and so we got to get the food to the to
the coral polyps we got to get the food
to the dead zones in the oceans
and we got to get the foods to the dead
zones in the swamps that's why we have
coal because there are dead zones in
swamps 500 million years ago
and all the algae
in the swamps died and became coal
okay that's why there's coal from
lack of oxygen hypoxia okay so when you
burn coal you're getting the minerals
were in
those algaes
300 to 500 million years ago
by putting those minerals or the wood
ashes or coal ashes into the gardens but
people don't do that anymore
uh very much
okay
and even now they put lights in their in
their fireplace instead of real wood and
real fires okay it's crazy
okay back to you
thank you
uh that's very true a lot of people are
putting gas fireplaces in and electric
fireplaces in and not using wood at all
we use wood at our house during the
winter and we actually put
all of the ash in a can and a bucket
after it's cooled so that when we go to
build our garden up
we mix it in the soil and my husband
rototills it so that there's ash in
there
well see
very important
it's essential these are essential
factors these are these are not a choice
yes
all right doc so we have several hands
up so let's go to the first hand up
which is archie fernandez
and archie if you could turn on your
camera that would be greatly appreciated
and i'm going to send you
where's archie from
i'm not sure
i sent him
what state is that in
archie is a person
i don't know fernandez is spanish i
think but he is not on muting
can you hear me anymore there you go i'm
sorry my um i'm on my office desktop and
my my web camera is not working i didn't
have time to to stop okay
so what's your question
my question is i have a friend who is on
dialysis
and um i i know i'm on the healthy start
pack i've been on for years
i also have been um following you for
years and i wanted to get some advice um
okay
how old is this person
uh he's 58
and how much does he weigh 170
and how tall is he
he's about five five
okay
the five five i'd like to see him
maybe weigh 150 so he's 20 pounds
overweight that's not too bad i think
just getting on the program he'll lose
that
okay
but um does he have any other issues how
would pressure diabetes
uh yes he has um diabetes he does have
high pressure um they
you know some of the meds that they have
given him uh i did look them up and one
of them was for high blood pressure sure
okay
okay well here we go
um high blood pressure is related to the
dialysis thing uh when the arteries
inside the kidneys are blocked the
kidney releases a hormone called renin
which drives your blood pressure up
hoping to get more blood to come into
the kidneys so the kidneys can filter
the blood
okay so the high blood pressure is
related to the dialysis stuff okay
and so what we want to do is get this
guy off all the bad foods no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no butter i know no sugar no carbs
or drinks even the diet one's got to go
because the carbonation of the diet
drinks neutralize stomach acid which is
required to absorb minerals and digest
food
then
at 170 pounds this guy needs two healthy
brain and heart patch per month full
dose everything twice a day is 215
nutrients okay 215 nutrients and the
classic 90 essential nutrients are in
there as well and then you have
uh
two
bottles a month of the msms you take
three at breakfast street lunch dinner
time
um that'll support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between the right bone makes your bone
itself
including liver and kidneys and heart
and so on
and then he needs the collagen peptides
the scoop of that goes in the
um
the morning breakfast
a drink and also scoop goes in the
afternoon or evening drink now the
collagen peptides takes the place of the
old
bone broth that we used to make when i
was a kid because we didn't have
electricity anything like that we made
our own bone broth it was messy and
sloppy and smelly and so he came out
with his collagen peptides to give you
the same
nutrients but without all the effort and
and so forth and the same mess and so on
um then
need vitamin d three three of those
twice a day uh two bottles a month so
you can absorb these nutrients and put
them in the right place
and then um
for the high blood pressure needs to get
two healthy brain and heart packaging
let me back up here two um bottles of
ultimate daily classic tablets two
bottles of ultimate daily classic
tablets to add to the two health branded
hard packs and they're designed to
support healthy blood pressure and
healthy blood flows through blocked
arteries including the kidneys
don't cold turkey off the blood pressure
medication but as blood pressure begins
to drop you reduce the blood pressure
medication bit by bit by bit based on
the numbers same thing with diabetes
diabetes
needs two bottles a month of our
sweeties take three of those twice a day
don't cold turkey off the diabetic
medication whether it's oral or
injection but as the
numbers begin to drop
they will be able to reduce
slowly slowly slowly reduce the
medication to pharmaceuticals for
diabetes usually in two to six weeks the
diabetes is gone usually within two to
six weeks the high blood pressure is
gone
and again i take people
who
were on dallas six days a week for 10
years because they hadn't urinated into
10 years put them on this program
and in two weeks time they're urinating
so they dropped the dialysis down to
three days a week instead of six and
then tumor weeks were totally off the
dialysis after 10 years of not urinating
um this is i do this every day
we're in 80 countries now and warehouses
in 60 countries and so we see
tens of thousands of people each day i
do zooms all over the world
um
including the same team that puts on
this uh wonderful program okay ruth
ellen and john t and rebecca and and the
sema
all these people
you know we in fact i was just on this
last tuesday a couple of days ago with
george dory for two hours in the evening
okay same same group
and they bring information out to a lot
of people so we're very very proud of
that thank you and but do give us a call
every couple of weeks because you're
going to have a great story for your
friend okay
thank you very much dr wallace you bet
god bless you sir wonderful program
thank you
have a great day you as well thank you
all right and our next hand up is
harold
so harold i'm going to send you a
request to unmute
this is harold all set
yeah is your camera available
uh sure is
all right
okay
that would be great
how can we help you harold
okay doctor thanks for uh taking my call
so i'm 60 years old
um i've been type 2 diabetic for
about 15 years
and i never really did my very good with
it i you know non-compliant for the most
part so this past february i had a blood
test
and my a1c was nine
and i i
cold turkey just changed my life around
i exercised i was always an athlete as a
kid
i exercise on a studio bike five days a
week for 30 minutes and then i have a
floor exercise i'm on a lot of your uh
supplements the sweeties um
the uh tangy orange arena the osceolf fx
i'm on uh
your buddy there uh um the uh uh cam
tumeric from you know george harry
pushes
um so
my blood sugars are average in about 140
now as i take them throughout the day
um
and i just want to get them down lower
okay how much you weigh
i've weight right now here's the thing
like i my weight over time fluctuated up
to 100 230 pounds i'm a kind of athletic
built but right now i'm 200 pounds i'm
three pounds away from my
uh weight that i was at home
i'm six foot
okay all right do you have any other
issues
okay on metformin okay do you have any
high blood pressure
uh
blood pressure yes
yeah he's got me on a maintenance but my
i i tracked that all the time
uh the last blood pressure was 100 over
98. okay that's with medication
uh i'm sorry it was 100 over 68. yeah
that was medication okay
okay okay stop stop stop do you have
anything going on with your joints do
you have any osteoporosis arthritis
noise clicking anything like that do you
have any dizziness any vertigo
no
any skin problems eczema dermatitis
psoriasis
nothing
bowel problems constipation diarrhea or
bowel syndrome did you have your
appendix out when you're a kid
no and i mean as far as the gi upset
sometimes and i think that i attribute
that to my metformin
mm-hmm
oh okay
all right
all right well here we go
remember metformin is an oral product
right yep now if you're not absorbing it
how much benefit are you getting from it
correct
okay so what we got to do is get you off
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no gluten no we
brought right now no sugar no carbon or
drinks either that one's got to go you
need to live like an asian you cannot
live like a european and eat european
type diets okay
with um you know things like pancakes
and waffles and oatmeal for breakfast
and
i haven't had any bread or carbs in this
house
since
february first i am okay okay
a month and a half okay good
yep so you're going the right direction
all right so here we go get rid of all
the bad foods eat like an asian
um yeah for breakfast i have baked sweet
potatoes with butter and our pink
himalayan salt on them okay along with
my
with my
soft boiled eggs or soft poached eggs
and then
uh this morning i had the fillet of tuna
okay about about an inch thick oh my
gosh and i am four inches in diameter
whoo it was good okay then i had yogurt
and i had all my supplements and so
forth and so you don't have to have a
boring breakfast sometimes i have
gluten-free pizza
okay made from cauliflower the crust is
made from cauliflower and has four
cheeses and like 10 different vegetables
on it but no processed meat you got to
take all the pastrami and pepperoni and
bacon and ham and all that kind of stuff
and either get
um
just cheese
gluten-free pizza okay
that kind of thing
and then so then i want you also
to
take that you're taking the sweeties you
can take three of those twice a day it's
your body weight three twice
one
currently i was i've only been taking
one with like
well that's you're you're you're trying
to shoot an elephant with a 22 okay okay
so three times a day three three times a
day
three so nine total
well you could take say take six seven
out of six go with six okay okay
and then you want to you know check your
blood sugar every day don't cold turkey
off your medication but as your blood
sugar begins to drop you can slowly
reduce the amount of medication based on
the numbers okay
okay same way with high pressure you
want two bottles a month of our ultimate
daily classic tablets
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three twice a day that's two vowels a
month and they're designed to support
healthy blood pressure and healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries
and so to make your kidneys happy make
your blood pressure happy and as your
blood pressure drops you can slowly
reduce the medication based again on the
numbers don't just cold turkey off the
medication
do you think my blood pressure at
um
90 over
like 68 is too low now no that's what
mine is without medication
okay
and i'm i'm 83 years old
okay okay
and so i i've been doing this for a long
time harold okay and so
most people when they look at me they
think i'm in my 50s is it well i can't
have done all that stuff how old are you
well i'm 83 what you look like you're
50. okay and that's because i've been
staying away from the bad stuff for 75
years
i've been taking all the good stuff for
75 years you can add 25 to 50 healthy
years
to your life that you can spend with the
people you love and do the things you
love to do if you just stay away from
the bad stuff and take in your 90. okay
so do give us a call every couple of
weeks because you're going to have a
great testimony and people are going to
hear this also kind of check your weight
because when you do this you won't be
eating as much
when you're taking in all these
nutrients particularly the minerals
because when you're deficient minerals
your body develops a a habit called pica
where you want to eat and eat and eat
because your body's looking for those
minerals and horses when they're missing
minerals they chew on the fence they
call it cribbing because in babies human
babies are missing minerals they chew on
the crib
the rail called cribbing
so taking yeah i i've been very happy
all these uh
supplements that i've been buying i've
i've had
for a few months now so okay well i want
you to change i want you to take your
change your vocabulary these are not
supplements these are essential factors
that are required
a supplement is something you can choose
to take or not choose to take okay
these nutrients are required just like
oxygen is not a supplement water is not
a supplement
okay these 90 essential nutrients are
not supplements they're essential
factors okay
we've got to change we've got to change
the language so that people understand
that these are more than something that
you know kooky people
you know who take all those quote
supplements unquote we don't we're not
going to stay there we're we're going
with essential factors
because they are as essential as oxygen
and water okay
very good
okay thank you look forward to hearing
from you sir
thanks so much ellen you bet bruce helen
back to you
thank you dr wallach and thank you
harold for your good question
okay so um
speaking of the vertigo and the
nutrients that we need dr wallach
when i first found you
um i had severe vertigo and from a fall
that i took and i was a limo driver
and i could not drive i couldn't walk on
anything basically the room was spinning
if i you know moved
and i could not hold the chiropractic
adjustment
and i started taking the bone healthy
bone and joint pack
and i started going gluten-free and i
used to weigh 235 pounds
and i started losing weight
and then i started after taking the
nutrients
i started to be able to hold my
chiropractic adjustments and then the
vertebrae and the discs and everything
started to rebuild and
i have not had vertigo in years
it took a couple months yes it took a
couple months it didn't happen overnight
and people forget that that's one of the
things people forget that
it takes time
you don't get somewhere
uh with your health overnight it happens
over time so you have to allow yourself
time to rebuild and always remember
that you need to watch your soy sauces
your barbecue sauces your
dressings and everything jack daniels
has a good really good gluten-free
barbecue sauce
and kikkoman has a gluten-free soy sauce
so there are a lot of options now that
weren't available
okay
and so to our next
uh question
uh wayne smith and thank you for turning
your camera on so i'm going to ask you
to unmute
yeah
very good thank you
good morning dr logic good morning sir
how can we help you
i'm calling on behalf of my spouse she
is 67 she weighs 135
she's five feet four
she has gold stone she does in fact have
high a gold stone problem came sometime
last year
she has been having high blood pressure
for many years
and of course she has you know lost her
sex drive
um i'm sorry stop stop stop i didn't get
that last she she has what she has lost
her sex drive
i'm missing something i can't understand
it she lost her sex drive oh she lost
her sex there's an x in there yes okay
okay
yes now she for the gallstone she's on
the protocol which is the healthy body
blood sugar pack
that's probably about three weeks now
and in addition to that she also uses
the ultimate daily classic
with respect to her blood pressure um
since we've been listening to your
program which is probably about three
weeks
she no longer take the blood pressure
medication daily but each morning she
checks it to see we attack
and
so far so good
okay good now let's go back to the
gallstones which is your first complaint
for her
uh does she have diabetes for high blood
pressure you should have high blood
pressure and she's taking the ultimate
daily classic tablet she's three of
those twice a day
um
let's see how much does she weigh 135
pounds i got it 35 pounds yeah okay
and so the gallstones we have what we
call the gallbladder and bottles our
ultimate enzymes that actually has bile
in it because bile is required for
healthful long life bile made in the
liver helps you absorb
the fat soluble vitamins like vitamin a
and and vitamin d
kind of things and vitamin k and so
forth also good fats essential fatty
acids and so forth are absorbed because
of the bile okay
and so she needs uh two
of the ultimate enzymes
say five to ten minutes for each meal
with a couple ounces of water
because
uh she has a liver problem here she's
got to stay away from all the bad foods
no gluten no weep on my nose says she
can absorb stuff and of course
if she's taking two of the healthy
brained heart packs uh per month that
she'll get two bottles a month of the
sweet
of the selenium in there which is part
of the health debate and hard packs and
in our selenium we have some unique
stuff that they don't have them all
green selenium so you want to make sure
she's getting those two healthy brain
and heart packs for months you want to
step up from the healthy start packs
healthy start packs are good and
actually they help the brain and heart
packs the core issue is the healthy
start packs and then we added another
115 nutrients on top of it okay
and then she needs the msm three of
those
um
twice a day that's one bottle a month
and they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
by itself the collagen peptides
you can take a scoop of that at
breakfast and her drink and a scoop of
that dinner drink again that's going to
deal with connective tissue in her skin
and her blood vessels and her heart and
valves and so forth
but also
um
she needs at the zera femme
xcra fem
zero femme yeah she takes yeah she can
take three of those twice it has two
bottles a month and they're the raw
materials that help the ovaries
make estrogen and progesterone
okay
and so that will help her a lot but make
sure she's eating at least
two or three eggs
twice a day
and because remember estrogen and
progesterone are 95 by weight
cholesterol she needs cholesterol she
cannot be on
uh statin drugs that lower cholesterol
if she's understanding drugs she got to
get off immediately so this is the you
know behind a lot of her problems if
she's on statin drugs or are consciously
avoiding gluten or excuse me consciously
avoiding cholesterol
okay
um if i made for myself
um
i'm 59 154
pounds
of 5 feet 7 and of course my issue is
just cholesterol the last time it was
checked it was the total number was 253
it was too low
the ldl was one
okay cholesterol 253 is too low it needs
to be up around 300
okay and doctors want to get it down
below 200 because it keeps the money
coming into them
okay
yes
that yeah which i've stopped sincere in
you in the past
yeah you need to be yeah yeah you need
to be up around 300 in your cholesterol
that'll make your brain work better
that'll give you more testosterone
remember testosterone is at 95
by weight cholesterol your brain is 75
by weight cholesterol
so everything works better when you're
eating more cholesterol it cannot be
fried
okay or burnt
okay but you can have you can have you
know like a medium rare i have medium
rare lamb chops every saturday night
that's my that's my treat how i treat
myself i have lamb chops
every saturday night okay but i also
have my three eggs twice a day at three
eggs in the morning and three eggs at
night with soft yolks uh cooked in
butter and so i'm getting my cholesterol
that way and you know being 83 years old
i don't have any problems
above my waist or below my waist i have
everything is cool okay everything works
like it's supposed to
and i don't have any blood pressure
issues i don't have any diabetes issues
i don't have any arthritis issues i
don't have any osteoporosis issues i
don't have liver issues i don't have
heart issues i don't have lung issues i
don't have skin issues
and i'm 83 years old
okay and that's why people think i'm 50
because you know i don't have any of
those issues because i'm giving my body
everything it needs okay these essential
nutrients these essential factors that
we require okay so if you do the same
give us a call every couple of weeks and
give us a story on your wife and
yourself you're going to have a happy
wonderful story
okay and i ask you with respect to
butter but about what amount per day can
one use
okay i didn't understand that she had
with respect to butter about what what a
margin one use per day how many ounces
okay a butter um let's just talking
sticks uh totally you could eat maybe uh
if you're exercising you can have maybe
a half a stick of butter a day between
breakfast lunch and dinner
okay
um yeah i go through about a half a
stick of butter a day
i only
and we 142.
all right thank you
okay thank you look forward to hearing
from you wayne sure all right
okay
okay it looks like that's all the hands
up for right now if anybody has a
question please please raise your hand
um it's better when doc can ask you
questions um adding
there's been a couple questions in the
chat that are very interesting
um so um i have a couple of email uh
questions that rebecca sent me to make
sure to ask
so we're going to go to one of those and
then okay
then we'll go to the chat
and this one is from sharon
the height is five foot seven inches
the weight is 143 pounds
she's 80 years old in december
i have the beginning of
scapular cataracts
no other health issues no other issues
am on no medications i take tangy
tangerine
look forward to any suggestions
regarding the above as i am
not interested in having cataract
extraction and
intraocular lens implant
okay
well 143 pounds
um you're right on that cusp
where you're
okay you want at least
uh one uh health abandoned heart pack a
half of those everything twice a day but
also you want to get an extra bottle of
arsenic not from all grains but
obviously with the five cofactors
because if you take three of those in
the morning and then there's
three in your full dose of the
um
tangy tangerine so you'll be getting two
bottles a month of the
of these selenium okay that's going to
help anti-inflammatory stuff um going on
on the lenses of your eyes
but no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no we probably rhinos no
sugar no carbonated drinks even the diet
one's got to go
and then
um
wouldn't hurt to
get another bottle of the efas and efa
pluses so you can take three at
breakfast and three at dinner time of
the efas and three at breakfast and
three
and breakfast and dinner time are the fa
pluses okay you need to make sure you're
getting those and stay away from strokes
and heart attacks and
all that kind of stuff
um bleeding and so on and then um let's
see here because of the eye and the
cataracts i also want you to get
uh our
btt 2.0 tablets now these are not a
replacement for the btt
2.0 powder which is our vitamins and
minerals the btt 2.0 tablets are
antioxidants and anti-inflammatories
which you want to do for your lenses and
your eyes so go ahead and take
one bottle of that per month that will
be three at breakfast for dinner time
and
they will help get the inflammation down
in your eyes you also want to take the
ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those twice as two bottles a
month they're going to support and
promote healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries and tiny little ories
in the eyes
the skull can be squeezing at 80 years
old the odds are you have some
osteoporosis of skull
squeezing the optic artery the optic
vein and the optic nerve
okay and which may be the root of your
problems with your eyes and doctors
don't know exactly what's going on so
they just say oh you have cataracts okay
and so um you do need to make sure
you're getting all those nutrients
get rid of the bad stuff and then call
us every couple of weeks because i think
you're going to have a great story
and
this stuff in the eyes goes away we do
have a book it's called it's all in your
head covers 25 different diseases
including the loss of vision
which includes pressure in the eye
cataracts
all kinds of stuff going on in the eye
because the skull is squeezing the optic
nerve the optic artery and the optic
vein when you have osteoporosis of the
skull so you want to get a hold of that
book
okay it's all in your head
and again you can you know get a hold of
this wonderful team here and they have
access to the books and the cds and
things and they can guide you in that
direction
okay
let's see here
um hey you have another email
there's a couple questions in the chat
okay and i also want to remind everybody
that you can listen to doc when he's
talking because we are recording this
and the recordings are available at
askdoclive.com
and you can just look for replays and
today's date and you'll find it there
um
okay so we have a young lady
um i'm not sure um
of age
she is here
i think it's julia
um
is on dialysis it looks like
i gotta find her are you able to talk
julia
i'm gonna ask you to unmute
and i'm gonna add you to the spotlight
hi
hi or julio sorry julio yeah it's okay
all right so i see your question but i
thought it'd be better if you could ask
doc and it looks like you are in the
hospital right now having your diapers
actually i'm doing dialysis right now at
this point in time and a dialysis center
yes
okay all right go ahead
okay um what i wanted to ask is um
sorry i'm kind of getting a little
nervous here but um it's okay yeah it's
okay it's just it's kind of weird doing
it here with all the stuff going on i
apologize for the background noise
no worries what i wanted to ask doc is
that my concerns is time i've been on
dialysis for about
two and a half years now and i'm trying
to find a way the best way to get off of
it completely
and
my current days right now is 53. i'm 5
feet 10 and 215 pounds
um my concern about it is that
the things that i now that i'm going
through it happens to be with the uh
the renal diet that i'm on and if i were
to do what you're saying
for eating certain foods
uh what's the best way to avoid like
spiking my phosphorus levels as well as
also potassium because i know that you
mentioned certain potatoes here and
there and i'm kind of like
i have to watch certain foods here and
there as well okay well you have to
appreciate doctors know nothing about
nutrition
right
okay
and if you want you can get a hair
analysis you know you can go to
www.drjwalik.com
and to get the book uh uh let's see here
rare earthmen cures chapter 10 tells you
how to collect the hair where to ship it
it'll tell us um if you're absorbing
it'll tell us what your levels of your
each of your nutritional minerals are
will also tell us if you have any toxic
metals like lead and mercury and uranium
and all that kind of thing going on in
there and so it's actually worth
definitely worth it especially if you're
on dialysis to find out what's going on
okay
and i guarantee you they didn't do a
hair analysis on you
okay um
so it's one of those things where
you may want to do a hair analysis once
every six months and uh
i think you'll be able to get off
analysis usually within weeks or a month
or two or something like that i do this
even people haven't urinated in 10 years
around analysis six days a week and
usually two to four weeks are off the
dialysis okay
uh this is very simple we've been doing
this for 50 years
we do this thousands of times
a day all over the world okay and so
basically
you say you weigh 215 pounds give or
take a little bit okay and so once you
get rid of all the bad foods which no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens or wheat bread right now so
sugar
um absolutely uh the diet one's gotta go
because they have carbonation in them
which neutralizes the stomach acid which
you require to absorb nutrients and
digest food and so forth particularly
minerals
and then um i want you to take two
healthy brain and heart pasture month
that's our big hammer two healthy
abandoned heart packs for a month the
full dose everything twice a day has 215
nutrients including the 90 essential
nutrients okay
then i want you to have two bottles a
month over msm so you take three with
breakfast three with the lunch through
dinner time and they will
help you
restore connective tissue in the walls
of your arteries the walls of your veins
um skin
uh in in the tubes in your liver the
tubes in your kidneys and so forth
um
your walls your bowels okay did you have
your panics out when you were a kid no
not at all okay good
good do you have gray hair
uh just very little changes of it not
too much okay okay this is not a
a
sort of a thing of aging when you have
white rare silver hair this is a
red warning light that says you're
deficient in a particular nutrient okay
and you're gonna you're gonna wind up
with aneurysms if you don't get that
hair color back okay right so you'll see
your hair color coming back with this
program so you know you're gonna reduce
the risk of aneurysms okay
so anyway
then i also want you to have a collagen
peptides put a scoop of that
a powder in your drink in the morning a
scoop of that in your drink in the
afternoon vitamin d three three of those
twice a day there's two bottles a month
and then i want you to have our ultimate
daily classic tablets two bottles a
month so you take three breakfasts from
dinner time and they're going to support
healthy blood flow
through your your kidneys also support
healthy blood pressure
okay okay um okay and don't if you're on
blood pressure medication don't go cold
turkey off of it but just as your blood
pressure drops you can slowly reduce the
medication based on the numbers okay
and then
you don't have diabetes do you or do you
um i'm pre-diabetic now i it got
reversed okay good so are you on our
sweeties
uh not at the moment
okay well you need to be on the sweeties
take three of those twice today
and um since you're not on medication
you don't have to worry about it but
you'll be amazed because your blood
sugar will drop significantly you'll get
it down to like you know fasting
pleasure should be in the 60s
okay that's very very easy to get down
to
and then that's the sweeties
and then of course i think we've covered
that that that
that the ultimate daily classic tablets
are where you need to go
to get off the dialysis okay and when
you go get your go to do your downside
doctor is saying we need to redo all
your tests here we've got the wrong we
got somebody else's information because
they're not going to believe
that
after all these years it's suddenly now
everything's coming right
okay because they depend on their
college tuition for their kids to make
sure that you keep coming in for
analysis for 25 years
right
okay
and so when it goes away in say four to
six weeks you're saying oh my gosh
and you know tell them we're happy to do
three ways if they want to get on the
show on fridays and we'll be happy to
answer their questions uh-huh okay okay
yeah thank you doctor i'll definitely
preach it once i get off this mess
okay julio look forward to working with
you brother thank you good hearing
you're on uh nori the other day oh he is
the greatest george is the greatest
yeah he is i appreciate the time sir
thank you bye-bye bye
thank you julio
all right um it looks like we have a
pop-in guest
rebecca is going to say hello to you doc
and everybody else
hello and good morning i apologize for
my background noises i am in the airport
getting ready to
head and have a presentation with
pharmacist ben but doc i just wanted to
say good morning and i love you and
we love you too
[Laughter]
okay so you're gonna be doing a zoom
with pharmacist ben all right
live live and zoom
live and zoom oh okay
yeah if anybody that would like to join
us for that you can go to
beckheaddukes.me
and you will see the information about
that and a way to register so that you
can get the zoom link for that sorry
okay well thank you everybody
your team is fabulous
yes they are
thank you
ruth ellen john t minasima
great team
dave travelton
alrighty doc it looks like wayne smith
has another question real quick okay and
a couple minutes we'll be taking a break
unless you want to take the break now
okay you know we can go a couple of
minutes okay let's go away
all right
i should have mentioned that since i
started on the aruba statin for the
cholesterol
that was last year i really lost um
my memory has deteriorated
so i i don't know
what would you need yeah you need to eat
the eggs right you need three eggs twice
a day and you need to get off the statin
drugs but i did
okay good and then you also need to take
our
uh synaptive take three of those twice
today add that to your program our
synaptive
product
synaptic like the synapse which is the
space between your brain cells okay
synaptive
syn
ap
tiv
okay
three twice a day
that'll give your brain cells the
nutrients they need to make the
biochemistry necessary to talk to their
neighbor's cells eat your eggs get your
cholesterol up in your blood and
cholesterol up in your brain 75 of your
brain weight is cholesterol
and then we also have memory effects you
can take three of those twice a day
memory fx
three twice a day
okay
yes thank you
okay then call us every couple of weeks
and let us know how the memory is going
okay so you can be einstein in two more
weeks
thanks thanks a lot
okay
that was a good question
all right doc let's take a break
okay we're gonna take a break all right
all right everybody
i just want to thank you for being here
we're gonna take a five minute break and
um
i also want to remind everybody that if
somebody invited you to watch ask doc
live or to participate in askdoc live
please get back to that person because
they have a vested interest in you and
if they cared enough about you to show
to share this with you then you know
that you're in good hands with them
because they do care
and um we also have a call team waiting
um and again if somebody invited you or
you're already a youngevity customer
please get back to the person who
invited you
or corporate
um so the phone team's phone number is
eight five five
nine 949
there are people waiting to help you
and um we will see you back here in five
minutes thank you
hello everyone good morning and good
afternoon
our break is almost over um my name is
ruth alan sanchez i am filling in for
our host
becca duke's rebecca dukes kozak who is
traveling today and i just want to thank
you all for being here and i want to
remind everyone that the fda requires us
to state that this is for educational
purposes only
not meant to diagnose treat
or replace your medical doctor
welcome back dr wallick let me unmute
you
when you're ready
and
um
so
there you go
there we are
yeah i had to take my jacket off because
it's 95 degrees here
oh that's good
it's very good
all right um so we have another hand up
and i'm going to spotlight you doc and
then
[Music]
is it nick
or nichi you have your hand up i'd like
you to unmute and if you can turn your
camera on that would be great
there we go
you're on with ask dr wallach on askdoc
live
hey
hi can y'all hear me
i apologize what's your name
nisha
mr
nishay
yes that's correct
okay
okay how can we help you
um so um i recently had a baby um almost
two years ago um i'm
i i'm overweight now um what do you
weigh anyway wait away uh i'm pushing
200 i'm 195 to 200. and how tall are you
five seven
okay and what's your age
i'm 31.
okay
i'm having i'm having concentration i've
had hair loss um i have joint pain in my
hip and i've been diagnosed with um tmj
disorder and they say i have 11
scoliosis as well um and i have energy
issues as well so
okay energy issues did you breastfeed
the baby
i did yeah
okay for how long
um about six months okay as long as i
could
okay so energy issues scoliosis
do you have any clicking or noise in
your hips or knees or anything like that
no clicking just pain in my right hip
when i stand um i i did purchase the gl
gluco gel uh i think i'm saying it
correctly and i have had some
improvement but it hasn't alleviated the
pain
okay and then as i see here constipation
did you say
no okay
what was the first one you said
concentration
oh concentration okay the other yes it's
really bad yeah okay
all right uh let's see here any diabetes
or highway pressure
no um i was told i had pre-diabetes
years ago but i just hit the gym and
that took care of that so nothing else
okay
all right any skin problems eczema
dermatitis psoriasis
i i get atopic dermatitis on my hands a
lot
okay
any ringing in your ears tinnitus
ringing buzzing or any vertigo balance
problems
no
did you have your appendix out when
you're a kid
no
okay good
all right uh this is not too unusual for
somebody who breastfed a baby okay
so number one at five foot seven i'd
like you know for a lady i'd like to see
you weigh about maybe
150 okay 150 kind of thing 170. so you
know 20 30 pounds we have
a product called um
it's a keto shake k-e-t-o shake
ketogenic shake keto shake
i think they come in strawberry and
chocolate one meal a day it's not to add
to a meal it's a meal replacer it is a
meal okay it's not to add to a meal it's
a meal replacer and then we have for the
energy we have the rebound rebounder
sports drink with 100 nutrients in it
most
um sports drinks are sugar and caffeine
ours are nutrients okay it's totally
different
and so you can take the two of those
uh at the same meal that you're doing
the keto shake okay
then i want you to have two healthy
brain and heart packs for months
two healthy brain and heart packs a
month that's 215 nutrients in each one
of them 215. okay
oh also
i want to back up a little bit when i
say get rid of all the bad foods the
fried foods the process needs the oils
the glutens the wheat broth i know sugar
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go
um
okay you need to get rid of all those
bad foods
okay and you got to get rid of statin
drugs
you got to eat three eggs twice a day
that's going to help with your
concentration
and then i want you to have the two
healthy brain heart factor month photos
i think twice a day i want you to have
uh two bottles a month for msm so you
can take three at breakfast food lunch
dinner time they're gonna support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between rubbery bone makes your
bone itself skin
your hip and back and all this kind of
stuff
and then um let's see and the tmj will
all go away
because um
the odds are you have arthritis but you
may also have
osteoporosis of the skull which is not
an aging thing
it has to do just with nutritional
deficiencies okay it's osteoporosis
skull when you have things going on in
your hips and your knees
you have stuff going on in your skull do
you have any receding gums or bleeding
gums or loose teeth
uh no but i i'm supposed to get braces
oh you're supposed to get braces okay a
little bit or a little bit late in life
or uh orthodontist but yeah that's
because you have osteoporosis or the
skull your teeth are floating around and
getting loose and all that kind of stuff
okay so yeah that's why you have that
issue osteoporosis of the skull
um the scoliosis all that stuff will go
away
and then
okay uh let's see here i want to make
sure i got everything
oh
um again you need the i said the
collagen peptides collagen peptides
that's um
a scoop at breakfast scoop at dinner
time vitamin d three three at breakfast
three dinner time that's two bottles a
month
and
i would go there okay since you don't
have any high blood pressure or diabetes
if you want to if you still have
pre-diabetes i'd go
with the two of the sweet two bottles of
sweeties every month so you can take
three twice a day
and um since you're not on medication
for diabetes correct
no i don't have anything okay good so
that that the
blood sugar should come down below 100
very quickly okay
and you're going to run to the doctor
you need to run to the doctor to find
that out you go to a pharmacy about a
prescription you can get one of two
things or both of them now you get test
strips that you can dip into some of
your urine to see if you have any sugar
in your urine you can also get test
strips and the little stickers you stick
it into your finger and put a drop of
blood on there and it'll tell you what
your blood sugar is
okay cost you a buck 35 per test
it's a lot better than spending a
hundred bucks for a doctor's visit and
sitting in that waiting room and
everybody coughing on you was a
with a covered
right
okay um also my daughter um they said
she has scoliosis too and she's 10. what
should i give her to what does she weigh
what does she weigh um she's about 90
pounds usually okay she's about half
your weight so what you want to do same
diet that you're on okay
but she needs to um
take half of everything you're taking
but everything you're taking but just
half
okay okay otherwise you wind up getting
everything you got okay
okay and as far as my um my toddler
for like what do we take for like a
regular
vitamin and mineral like did we get the
which one do we get
it's called kids toddy
and the
dosage by weight is on the back of the
bottle on the back label okay it's kid's
toddy you also want to
give this child
the cherryman's use the same
dosage
information and then also the efas
okay there's soft shell capsules
um they have the liquid efas in them we
have the ifa pluses how much does your
child weigh 90 pounds you say yeah she
could take my 10 year old yeah yeah yeah
she could take um
two of the fa's twice a day into the fa
pluses twice a day okay
and this is gonna be a miracle both you
ladies are gonna do wonderful
and the baby can take the kids tiny as
well
well the baby everyday vitamin oh yeah
that's who i was giving you the kids
daddy for when she's
when your child does not weighs 90
pounds she's going to have everything
you're taking
which is half a dose no my i have a 10
year old and a one year old i mean i
know about the one year oh the one year
old is the kid's tiny
okay
and then i don't need an everyday
vitamin is it all in the list that you
gave me yes right
okay you're good you're good to go but i
want you to call us every couple of
weeks because you're going to have a
great story your story is not uncommon
but call us every couple of weeks and
let us know what goes on you go to a
doctor for a checkup or whatever and
he's going to say well whatever you're
doing keep doing it because you know
this is looking good and this is looking
good or he's going to say we may have to
get people to say well doctor wanted to
rerun on my test because he couldn't
believe the results he was saying he ran
all the tests and came back
he said well it doesn't look like we
need to make an appointment for you
anymore
that would be great yep
okay thank you very much
okay very good to talk to you
thank you very much
and your daughter if she doesn't like
the tiny tangerines the 10 year old
could definitely continue to take the uh
kids toddy because it's delicious and
easy to get in them
all right
awesome
all right so we have
a question that was sent in by email
this is our second question that that
was emailed to us
doc um and the name is damiana
and she suffers from light i'm sorry
right lower lumbar sharp nerve pain
radiating to her buttocks her hip her
inner thigh
and radiating radiating down the side of
her right leg to knee
she says i had a neurostimulator implant
in seven of 2020
and it's been great however recently in
between
charging my stimulator and the and the
battery pack one to two hours
and when sleeping i suffer between eight
as i suffer between eight to ten pain
level
i had successful surgery
rrl
on
l5 through l6
with in with fusion in 2018.
how much does she weigh
um she did not give any of those details
okay sorry we'll go but okay we'll go by
a hundred pounds okay
yeah i'm gonna give you dosages for 100
pounds any other issues how about
pressure diabetes
nothing was lifted
okay so mainly her back and her hips and
legs and all that kind of stuff right
yes sir
okay
so let's go by a hundred pounds of body
weight she's gonna have to get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no brighter iron oats no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go because the carbonation
interferes
with the absorption of minerals and the
digestion of food
okay you require stomach acid to do all
that
and then per 100 pounds of body weight i
want her to have
uh one
of the healthy abandoned heart packs for
a month and b if she only weighs 110
pounds she could take a half a dozen
everything twice a day if she weighs 200
pounds she needs to take two health
abandoned heart packs for months okay
because we're talking dosage for 100
pounds of body weight right
and then i also want her to have
one bottle a month per 100 pounds of
body weight of the msm she per 100
pounds of body weight she can take three
of the msm tablets the breakfast for
dinner time
and they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae bone makes
your bone itself this is a perfect
supplement for her okay
she also needs
the collagen peptides i wanted to have a
scoop of that and her breakfast every
morning breakfast drink a scoop of
collagen peptides and her breakfast and
her evening drink
and then
i also want her to have
the cal toddy uh she needs per hundred
pounds of body weight one ounce of cow's
toddy per day so she weighs 110 pounds
she can have a half ounce of the cal
tidy breakfast a half ounce of the cow
tidy dinner time if she weighs 150
pounds to 200 pounds she needs two
ounces a day one ounce of breakfast one
ounce of dinner so it'll be two quarts a
month it's a liquid
tastes good
okay i mix it with my drink okay i mix
my cal tidy with the drink so it's just
all at one time
and then
uh let's see here
she's also going to need
the fucoid see three of those twice a
day
okay that's anti-inflammatory and also
supports the immune system
also i want her to take
for the pain
we have cm cream and also the trauma oil
in our aromatherapy all divisions you
can put 10 drops of our trauma oil
in a
teaspoon
of the cm cream apply that directly to
the painful area whether it's in her
ankle her hip or knee
and
she will be able to get pain relief for
about two to three hours a half hour
before bedtime i want her to use our sue
that's from our hemp fx division and the
hemp fx soothes s-o-t-h comes in a
little pump bottle
and you can use uh
that's the
uh cbd oil with no thc in it so it's
perfectly legal uh t
cvd oil plus a
handful of herbs and everything that
reduce pain and inflammation swelling
and so you can put that on her
wherever she has pain
um a half hour before bedtime and she'll
get four or five hours of pain relief
while she's sleeping
okay
okay thank you very much and also doc we
have a hemp fx roll-on
that works wonderfully as well
okay well there you go
yes
okay um it looks like archie may have
another question
um and i want to encourage everybody to
please raise their hands so that we can
ask doc questions uh there's a couple
questions in the chat that i will find
while archie is asking his question
okay
if you could unmute and if you can turn
your camera on
uh again i uh my camera is not working
oh that's right that's right
guys for that i'll make this real quick
i don't want to deprive anyone else of
uh um being able to ask a question um
just uh i forgot to ask uh dr wallach i
know when i do my um
uh my tangy tangerine i usually put a
whole lemon uh in with it with two eggs
and um
that's
when i do that is that a problem with
rawr eggs no
okay
not a problem okay and then can i just
um just a quick testimonial of dr
wallach because i had
my uh my godfather this he's since
passed away now but when he was 87 he
had a very severe hip issue they
basically put him in a wheelchair
um he uh was um
uh was smart enough to realize that he
wasn't gonna go for an operation at his
age and i said do you want to try
something else he said i'd do anything
such severe pain
uh i got him on your protocol
and within uh was uh
actually
uh three weeks and five days he no
longer had to have
uh percocet
uh was able to actually cut his grass at
87 years old
um and i guess that's the end of the
story just uh people just don't realize
uh how important nutrition is
yes well i'm 83
and i can do all that i can i can cut
the dress chop trees unload trucks
load trucks uh it's
because
uh i'm built
and and maintained the same
physical capability as a 50 year old
who's in good shape
and so everybody can do this okay the
good lord made us to
think in the old testament says and
man's years shall be 120. and then when
you look at some of the
disciples and so forth they lived to be
300 700 even the methuselah would be 969
that's almost a thousand years okay
and so the the thing to hit depreciate
is that
your bodies require these essential
factors
our bodies require these essential
factors and when the doctor says don't
waste your money on vitamins metals just
take
you know just take the
four food groups take the seven food
group pyramid and you'll be fine well
that doctor should have his license
taken away and put into jail
because you cannot get everything you
need from your food because nutritional
minerals do not occur in uniform blank
around the trust of the earth they
current veins like gold and silver
and most people are not going to get
anything close to the nutrients they
need the mineral nutrients you need 60
but what if you're only getting six or
seven or ten you're missing 50 and
that's why you have all these issues
you're on 25 different prescriptions
you're seeing 14 different doctors your
whole life is going to and from doctor's
offices and clinics and test
laboratories and so forth that's no way
to live but but insurance pays for it
well okay if you're happy go for it but
thank you very much okay thank you okay
archie thank you sir
thank you archie
all right
all right doc we have like miles is
giving me a hard time sorry about that
um
we have a question in the chat from ea
and i don't know what these initials
stand for
so i'm just gonna read the question
and um ea if you're available to um
it comes from e-a-i-o-u
no yeah
that's her initials e-a i don't know
what her full name is and i just lost
the question i'm so sorry um
bear with me one moment i had it up
goodness
technology sometimes can be so fun
um
in the meantime
i i can i can also i can also prevent
gender issues
okay
uh because again a gender is determined
in the first couple of weeks of
pregnancy
and so your your hypothalamus in the
center of your brain determines who
you're going to chase for sex and who
you're allowed to chase you for sex and
if mama's missing stuff
during that time when that part of the
brain is forming in the embryo in the
first couple of weeks of pregnancy uh
the baby is going to have a gender issue
um when the baby says you know it's five
six years old and says and so it's a
little girl mommy i want to be a boy
unless he's a little boy mommy i want to
be a little girl
okay you already have a hint that
there's something going on there and you
get to get these kids on the 90th of
nutrients you need to get them
on um the eggs for the cholesterol
because 75 percent of our brain weight
is cholesterol you need to get them on
our hgh our human growth hormone which
is good for the pituitary the adrenal
glands and the brain but also
need the if it's a little biological boy
who wants to be a girl you can give them
the zera test if it's a biological girl
who wants to be a boy you can give them
the zero femme
and
a percentage will come right it depends
on how severely damaged the hypothalamus
is it's just ten percent damage is it's
kind of a repairable thing it was 90
damage we may not get a complete
resolution but it's totally preventable
okay and in the earliest of the stages
many will be reversible okay
thank you dr
all right so i have found um ea's
question
it says hi doc
trying to find out if there's anything i
can do to prevent amd
my mother got it at 75 to 78 and now i
have a floater in each eye i wish i knew
what i should be eating to prevent this
what vitam vitamins i should be taking
i'm age 71
140 pounds
woman
who is
foot five
okay
okay so you've got medicare she got
mature degeneration in the eye i'm
assuming
her mother her mother did and now she
has floaters
okay so she's got floaters so she's
concerned what's coming
yes yes sir
okay
so
at 140 pounds she's getting all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no gluten the wheat bread around
notes no sugar no carbon or drinks even
the diet one's got to go 140 pounds
she's right on that cusp
okay and so if she's concerned about
certain things that her family had i'd
definitely go with two healthy brain and
heart packs a month or full dose
everything twice a day i'd get one
bottle a month of the msm so she can
take three twice a day the msm support
and promote maintenance repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue which is also includes the globe
of the eye and the lens of the eye okay
and um
then
she needs to also take the collagen
peptides
again a scoop of that with her breakfast
drink a scoop without her evening drinks
she needs two bottles a month of our
vitamin d3 so you can take three twice a
day uh so she can absorb the minerals
and put them all in the right places and
we'll also want her to have
our ultimate daily plastic tablets take
three of those twice a day it's two
bottles a month and they're designed to
support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries and healthy
blood
pressure but this will also be true for
the eyes and also the formula i gave her
is going to help her with osteoporosis
of the skull which can be squeezing the
optic nerve the optic artery the optic
vein which can cause all these things
pressure in the eye goes up
and they get all kinds of issues and the
eye doctor can't quite put their finger
on it so they say oh you have max
regeneration oh you have
um
you know you've got a pre
thing here going on with the lenses of
your eyes we may have to do lens surgery
on your eyes okay
and so the doctors you know they're
already looking into the future here so
they can make enough money to pay the
the
fees for their kids go to college okay
but these are all preventable all
reversible
very good thank you very much dr wallach
so um i have a question because you've
mentioned it a couple times and i was
just curious and i'm sure other people
are you've asked a couple people if they
had their appendix taken out
why is that and
something you want to know okay well
that's because your appendix
hooks into your colon right where the
small intestine hooks in the colon so
there's a small intestine the appendix
and a colon all in one place
and when people have a gluten issue
they get irritable bowel syndrome ibs
they get
let's see here
crohn's disease celiac disease
diverticulitis but they also can get
appendicitis and so when you get a kid
who's six years old or seven or eight or
ten years old and hasn't had their
appendix taken out they are eating
oatmeal for breakfast they're eating
pancakes and waffles for breakfast
they're eating flour tortillas they're
eating spaghetti three nights a week
okay
they're eating bread with every meal
they're putting a whole
half a box of crackers in their soup and
that kind of stuff
okay
and so so that tells you how long
they've been that's why i asked people
about the color of their hair because we
have white gray or silver hair that has
nothing to do with age that is to do the
nutritional deficiency but that same
nutritional deficiency that causes white
green silver hair a lot of hair pigment
um it means that you are going to have
an aneurysm in your brain you're going
to have an aneurysm in your aorta
all kinds of blood vessel problems
and so
that tells me where i need to go
and so those questions are not asked
lightly those are very important
because the body's already responding is
and so white hair white gray and silver
hair has a red warning light she's like
on the dashboard of your car
do you ignore it do you ignore that red
warning light when it comes on no you
pull over and try and
check your oil level and all that kind
of stuff and check your water level
and you know and so on and so you need
to do the same thing for yourself
okay
okay thank you very much
all righty so harold typed into uh the
chat
to one of the co um
co-hosts
um hi doc what do you think of fenugreek
pill form or tea which is better
okay i don't have an opinion on
fenugreek because i personally don't use
it
okay okay but we do have a book um
let's play herbal doctor and everything
probably about fenugreek is in there
yes it is
well there you go
all right thank you doc
and then we have another emailed in
question
um
from danny
wondering if you have anything that can
help with
helping me with mold allergies along
with
emf
uh electromagnetic field and mcs uh
electric magnetic field oh we okay sorry
so it's electromagnetic field and
multiple chemical sensitivities the mold
allergy i believe is the worst that
makes the others bad as well
thanks for anything you can help me with
so you don't have an age or weight or
anything no
that's all i have okay
okay let's go by a hundred pounds of
body weight okay and okay and so yeah
when somebody sends an email you have an
address so you email them back and say
hey we need your weight and your age and
all this kind of stuff
and we'll be be more accurate okay yes
sir
okay so
uh again going by per 100 pounds of body
weight when people have chemical
sensitivities
and they have um
all kinds of allergies and stuff like
that
that has to do with digestion okay and
so basically
um you want to take care of your immune
system you want to take care of your
digestive system get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils or gluten they'll weep out
rhinos no sugar no carbonated drinks
yeah the diet one's got to go
and then they need
the
90 essential nutrients or better yet the
healthy branded heart pack
one per 100 pounds of body weight
and then
wouldn't hurt for them also to throw in
the ultimate daily
classic
tablets three of those twice a day for
blood flow
and blood pressure issues they also need
to
throw in the collagen peptides a scoop
of that in their breakfast drink to
scoop that evening drink because when
you have
problems with chemistry in your food
that kind of thing chemicals and
allergies and so forth your bone marrow
is your best friend okay
and your bone marrow is your best friend
because it
has to do with white blood cells
uh has to do with platelets
red blood cells
let's see here
antibodies antihistamines all are made
in your bone marrow
so you really need those collagen
peptides when you have these issues that
she's got okay
and then
okay and then you want to stay away from
allergenic foods okay
the foods that are you know allergenic
uh are
grain
and bread
and pancakes and waffles and oatmeal and
beer made from wheat butter and oats if
you want to drink beer drink beer made
from rice which you can get um in most
um
liquor stores they have you know lime or
rice
containing beers and whiskeys and stuff
like that
uh stay away from the wheat broth rhinos
even in drinks
okay
and then we have then we have an
anti-inflammatory
um
it's called killer biotic it's actually
have a different name it's called killer
biotic it's arising mushrooms
anti-inflammatory
as well as supporting the immune system
so that's where we need to go there
three twice a day per hundred pounds of
body weight of the killer biotic so
three twice a day that'll be two bottles
a month because they're small bottles
okay
thank you very much
and then there's a follow-up question
about the appendix
let me get back into my phone
it says john ireland would like to know
does the appendix refurbish good
bacteria in the gut
okay that's not the purpose of the
appendix the purpose of the appendix is
to
[Music]
make antibodies and white blood cells
and stuff like that so that in this
very very high traffic area where your
small intestine colon appendix are at
all this stuff is going on okay um and
so it's imperative
you know people talk about um
good bacteria okay right
good bacteria
okay and people always want oh we have
to have the good bacteria
well
you have to appreciate that the good
bacteria
are bacteria
bad bacteria are bacteria
and so whatever you're ramping up for
the good bacteria
is going to negatively affect the good
bacteria if you ramp up stuff for the
good bacteria to make more of those
you're going to also ramp up for the bad
bacteria
okay
and so
you need to make sure you're using the
hand sanitizer the colloidal silver
those kind of things
and so um
you have to appreciate
that um
uh
you have to pay attention all these sort
of details and that's why and that's why
we have the book so let's play doctor
let's be herbal doctor passport wrong
with their insulin your head
it tells you
um
how to
deal with this in such a way you're
getting the best
result
and avoiding the negative
but you have to
um which i say tread
along a track you can't be inventing
things and running around doing stuff
that
that's why we publish this stuff in the
books and again
we have the new
um
brochure out okay
and the new brochure out has um
21 books i i've published 22 books ones
in the smithsonian institute sells for
25 000 of these so we don't um put that
one on here but we do have a summary of
it it's called epigenetics and of course
i urge everybody to begin to build a
little bit of a library of these books
and they will the information can add 25
to 50 healthy years your life it will
save an enormous amount of unnecessary
misery you'll save an enormous amount of
money you can add 25 to 50 healthy years
your life
by following the protocols in these
books
and um
what can i say
um these books
are all over the place the dead doctors
don't lie
okay this to
is in nine languages which sold 600
million copies and of course
the
newest one which just came out not too
long ago
okay the truth about nutrition is a
20-year update on dead doctors don't lie
and this has a book a cd and a dvd you
can only buy the set you cannot buy just
the dvds only you cannot buy the cds
only you cannot buy the book only got to
buy the whole set
and
if you buy 10 sets at one time we'll
give you a 10 discount on each set so
you save 100 bucks right there okay
okay thank you very much
and we also have um i-26 hyper-immune
egg powder
which helps balance the gut bacteria and
gets rid of the bad bacteria without
harming the good bacteria correct
that's correct yeah all right there we
go i i 26
perfect
okay um i have a question in the chat
from
monica
she is
five foot six
135 pounds 67 years old
both my twin and i wake up
whenever
with dry mouth
we don't take pharmaceutical drugs
okay well if they wake up with dry mouth
they may be dehydrated that may not be
drinking enough fluid
okay that's a possibility
and so they might try
um drinking more liquid during the day i
wouldn't drink a quarter of water before
you go to bed because you'll wake up a
couple of times at night to go to the
bathroom okay and so but you want to
increase your fluid intake during the
day
okay and of course we have a sports
drink called rebound with a hundred
nutrients in it there's no which i say
there's none of the bad stuff
in the rebound it has 75 minerals and 25
bottoms amino acids and so forth
but
they need the 90 essential nutrients 135
pounds right on that cusp i would go
with one healthy brain and heart pack
per month
half a dose twice a day
they also need one bottle a month of the
msm so you take three twice a day uh
it's a big body be able to do that and
it will support and promote maintenance
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes upon itself
skin rv walls vein walls all kinds of
stuff
uh the walls of your intestines so that
msm is very important then don't forget
the collagen peptides and scoop of that
in your breakfast drink in the morning
and scoop that in your evening drink
and uh it takes a place of grandma's
um bone broth which is messy and smelly
and all that kind of stuff to make and
most people don't eat have enough bones
in their diet to make bone broth so we
have come up with the collagen peptides
to replace the old bone broth recipe
which is very useful for getting
minerals for your bones
and your bone marrow cavity okay
that's why we have the um
the collagen peptides
okay perfect
perfect
and rebecca has just posted a question
in the chat
that says male 52 years old
340 pounds
severe ptsd and
after service as a marine
phone on bone knees he's six foot two
no blood pressure or sugar issues had a
gastric sleeve in 2014
hematoma
crosses
and she said he was 450 pounds and he is
now down to 340.
okay
all right
so
well first of all thank him for his
service
okay
and then we want to make sure that this
guy is getting rid of all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils and gluten wheat bread rhinos no
sugar no carbonated drinks
and then i want him to have one meal a
day this is a meal replacer this is not
to add to a meal this is a meal replacer
okay this is to add two meals
it's a meal replacer to add to him
not to add to a meal but it's a meal
replacer and that is our keto shake
comes in strawberry and chocolate i
believe
and so one keto shake just one not three
just one keto shake and then also uh it
needs the rebound or sports shrink with
100 nutrients and he can have two of
those rebound drinks uh with his keto
shake meal okay and he'll lose a half a
pound of two pounds a day
and it um
he said
how tall is he is he five foot six did
you say
um i believe it was six foot two and he
also has sleep apnea she just told me
yes six foot two
six foot two okay six foot two
okay so sleep issues okay
all right so
again none of the bad stuff
then at 340 pounds i wanted to have
three of the um
healthy brain and heart packs for months
now if finance is an issue don't go
lower than two but optimal would be
three uh full dose of anything at
breakfast philosophy lunchtime full or
dinner time
okay
then also needs two bottles a month in
the msm so you take three with breakfast
through the lunch three dinner time and
they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between the vertebrae bone makes bone
itself that includes
the connective tissue in the walls of
arteries and veins so they don't break
and bleed
don't form aneurysms
okay
and so forth
and uh also will lower blood pressure in
case you've got a blood pressure a lot
of people when they have blood pressure
issues and they're on medication and the
center blood pressure is under control
they don't talk about it because they
think well i've got under control
but we can get rid of it okay
and then um they'll call some of the
bleeding uh as a bone marrow issue
because it's not making
uh the
platelets okay
and so this is where the collagen
peptide comes in the scoop of the
collagen peptides in the morning drink
and the scoop of collagen peptides in
the evening drink so the bone marrow can
make platelets and white blood cells and
red blood cells and antibodies and so
forth to prevent bleeding in the brain
and
the heart and the lungs and all over the
place
then
also
uh he's gonna lose about a half a pound
two pounds a day
i'll see here for the ptsd i want him to
have our memory effects you can take
three of those with each meal it'll be
three bottles a month memory effects
three at each meal i also want them to
have our synaptive three with breakfast
food lunch for dinner time there will be
three bottles per month of synaptic
and that's going to
calm everything down
uh let's see here yeah let's let's do
that
and i think we have
taken care of everything including he
will lose a half a pound of two pounds a
day on his um
um
weight
and
the sleep issue
okay the the synaptive
and the
um
the other issues that help the brain
like the cholesterol and the eggs is
very good 75 of the brain weight is
cholesterol he should not be taking any
statin drugs or lower cholesterol his
cholesterol should be up around 300
doctors want to get it below 200
because that means that your insurance
company will put their kids through
college if you get down below 200 okay
you don't want to do that
okay
um but anyway um
this is all resolvable i see this a lot
i deal a lot with veterans i spent seven
years in the army in 20 years in the air
force i retired as lieutenant colonel in
the air force
i apologize for not being a marine but
we love you and and
we
know that you're going to do well
because you are a marine
okay
thank you very much dr wallach
also um
de-stress me would be good as well
correct
oh yeah you can throw in the de-stress
absolutely
all right perfect all right so we have a
hand raised yeah if you're going to take
the de-stress you need three with each
meal that'll be two bottles a month
they're
semi-big bottles so you take three at
breakfast food lunch for dinner time and
the de-stress
okay perfect thank you
so john it looks like you have your hand
up i'm going to ask you to unmute
and you're on with dr wallach good
morning doctor good morning sir how can
we help you um last time i talked to you
i told you that going right through here
and right through here i had a headache
that pulsated
and um
i went and had an mri done
and up in here there's a little white
spot that they told me
is not getting enough oxygen
over here there's a small growth inside
the sinuses
and there's a small growth on the liver
um
so i've been
mulling over the
hyperbaric chamber buying one and
putting it in the garage
so i went and tried one
and uh i
i i did about an hour there i couldn't
stand much more it was so claustrophobic
um
but the headache went away
but now it's that was last friday
and now it's starting to come back just
a little bit yeah well the hyperbaric
chamber will put more oxygen into your
blood that's the purpose one of the
purposes of it okay
and so that's why you got some benefit
so here we go how much you weigh
225 pounds
okay how tall are you
six foot
okay what's your age
uh 76 this month
okay you have white grayish over here
yes
okay did you have your panics out when
you're a kid
nope nothing ever no asthma no
bronchitis no bowel problems no bowel
syndrome nothing
just the allergy that i talked to you
about last and i stepped up all the
things that you uh prescribed
and that is starting to go away
okay good so keep going there
did i tell you to take oxybody
since you had such good success with a
hyperbaric you should if it didn't add
oxybody it should add or oxy body and
it's your body you take it out twice a
day the oxy body be two parts a month
it's a liquid oxygen supplement tastes
good even little kids like it
and so i don't know
you know that'll increase the oxygen
level
and okay and then
um
the white green silver here has to do
with nutritional deficiencies okay that
has not had anything to do with aging
but it gives you a signal that there's
you're going to have something going on
here you'll have aneurysms and things
like that you have blood clots
and so again the collagen peptides you
need a scoop of that with your morning
drink and a scoop of that with your
eating drink technology and peptides who
want to get the big canister
and then
you went to two healthy branded heart
packs for months you need the msm two
bottles of that so you take three
with each meal
uh you need the
let's see here i talked about the body
also should take an extra two quarts a
month of the cal toddy taking out some
breakfast out of dinner time
and that's going to cover a lot of
territory okay so call us every couple
of weeks
um at the six foot 225 if you're in good
shape and it's not all in your belly
that's not bad
but you will lose weight because your
hunger is going to go down you're
wanting to have six desserts will go
away kind of thing
there's a
behavior called pica p-i-c-a when you're
nutritionally deficient particularly in
minerals your body says eat eat you need
to find that nutrient eat eat you need
to find that nutrient that's why people
gain weight because they're they have
pica p-i-c-e-p-i-c-a
and in horses they call it cribbing and
little babies who who
sleep in a crib they call it cribbing
when they chew on the rail
on you know the up and down rail on the
crib
and so
you
go ahead
i'm doing everything you said except
oxybody
and what was that one other one
um
the other one
there's one other one you said oxybody
and something else
okay well there's the um
uh
um oh the msm
what
i was gonna say this is recorded you can
go back and watch the recording do that
yes do you feel about um
getting up every morning at four in the
morning and going out in the garage
getting in a hyperbaric chamber for 90
minutes every day
well i would say that that's too much
okay if you have to do that as soon as
you start taking this oxy body within a
week or so you won't need to do that
okay
okay very good it's been two to spend
two two hours
uh every morning that early in the
morning you know in
a microwave so to speak
it's
it's going to get you in trouble driving
and so forth
you're going to fall asleep and get in a
crash
okay
very good thank you
thank you very much don
yes let's just hear from you don okay
thanks
okay what else we got here
all right
we have time for one or two more
okay yes we do um i have
um
i have a email question and then we have
a gardening question from monica that we
will get to um if we have enough time
um so this is from kevin b
and it says hello rebecca i hope all is
well with you
please ask dr wallick his thoughts on
polycystic kidney disease i just found
out someone close to me has this genetic
disorder
and would like to know the best steps to
keep it at bay on your friday stream
thank you and god bless chris okay
okay well first of all polycystic
kidney disease is not genetic
okay polycystic kidney disease babies
can be born with it they can get it
later in life
it's where the
the fluid
transferring
tubes get plugged somewhere along the
line and so you get a blister full of
urine
okay that's the cyst gets filled with
urine because it can't flow through
because it's either bent or twisted or
uh got narrow
or something like that
and
uh you know doctors oh we need to do a
kidney transplant well what i wanted to
do is get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
or gluten the wheat bar right now so
sugar no carbohydrate drinks either that
one's got to go
they need per 100 pounds of body weight
one healthy brain heart pack per month
um one bottle of the msm saying take
three twice a day
um one
of the big canisters the collagen
peptides so they could take a scoop of
that at breakfast drink scoop with that
dinner drink they need vitamin d three
two the bottles of that per month they
can take three breakfasts from dinner
time
and then for the for the kidneys very
important for the kidneys is the
ultimate daily classic tablets get two
bottles a month they can take three and
breakfast at three at dinner time and
they will support healthy blood pressure
healthy blood flow
through the blocked arteries and the
kidneys
and usually the polycystic kidney
disease will quiet down and and simply
go away
okay
okay perfect thank you
all right and then we did have one more
email question
um it's from christy
and it says what do you do about
peyronie's
of the penis
okay well that's where the penis
kind of heads off to the right or heads
off to the left right
yeah and so basically
this is caused by a connective tissue
issue so they need you know the msm they
need the collagen peptides
they need the zero test three of those
twice a day is there a test and i think
um
it's back ordered until may 1st
okay may 1st which is just a couple of
weeks from now uh it'll be out again
but um yeah three
of the um
uh
see here
you know three three of the um
male
okay so the zero test
okay twice a day
don't forget the three eggs twice a day
with soft yolks because that's 75
percent of the brain weight is
cholesterol and 95 of the weight of
testosterone is cholesterol
and i think that will cover it
perfect thank you so much dr wally
okay
all right so i want to remind everybody
that um if you want to ask a question by
email it came up in the chat um please
go to askdoclive.com
and click on contact us and you can
email us there and one of our holistic
health coaches will respond to you
and we will ask your question on
ask.live as well
and we did have another question
about uh gophers
and moles destroying somebody's garden
and they want to know what to do and if
you had any suggestions
yeah well we have
we don't have but there are there's
available traps i don't like to put out
poison because then dogs and cats can
eat the poison
and so
you know rather than spend a lot of
money hiring a big team to come out
there and put the
the um
a hose from the exhaust pipe of a car
and get carbon monoxide down in there
you've still got to dig up the hole and
get rid of the dead bodies
um
you can also put traps
okay you put traps right by their hole
where they go in and out and put traps
there put a little bait in there you
know something like a dog foot or
something like that
in the trap and they'll go in there and
set off the trap and get caught and then
you could take them to the humane
society if you want to and let them
either give them to a zoo or
or
the humane society can
you know can
put them to sleep so any rate those are
options
okay thank you very much
okay i think i'm going to head out of
here
um
i've got a long way to go here today so
i'm going to
take off and thank you
thank you rose ellen thank you john t
thank you
um
just a few more minutes but if you need
to go doc that's good um fine
well i don't want to be talking about
trapping moles and stuff like that
so i was gonna ask you we have about
four minutes left
um
several people have been talking about
exercise and i know one of your favorite
sayings is exercise without
supplementation is suicide so that is
correct and dead athletes touch on that
briefly if you'd like and then we'll say
goodbye
okay well
doctors have a wrong idea and say say oh
just eat the four food groups and the
nine food group pyramid or the seven
food group pyramid whatever it is
and um you'll get everything you need
don't waste your money on vitamins and
minerals when a doctor who says that
should be put in jail okay they should
have their license taken away uh in in
1936 the u.s senate came out with a with
a um saying u.s senate document 264 that
said
americans farm soils no longer have
enough nutrition to support life
you said that 1936.
and so doctors today saying oh just see
well you get everything you need
electricity has killed more people than
all the wars in the world combined okay
and that's because we gave up wood ashes
which were our universal source no
matter what country you came from
everybody in the world was putting wood
ashes into their gardens and wood acid
and their food and they're getting what
minerals were there now wood ashes
uh you have variable amounts of minerals
in them because nutritional minerals do
not occur in uniform blank around the
crest of the earth they current veins
like gold and silver
and that's why i like our pink himalayan
salt because it does have 78 minerals in
there
as well as the sodium chloride
and so you can take the the pink heavily
in salt i do i take it for breakfast
lunch and dinner pink himalayan salt
and um
i also um
which i say
is i do exercise i walk three miles a
day
every day i've been doing it for 75
years and i played sports i played
football i played um
i wrestled i played soccer
rugby all that kind of stuff i ran track
weight lifted
power lifting and all kinds of stuff and
so uh you know
exercise is okay if you supplement with
the 90 essential nutrients
and replace what you're sweating out but
if you just exercise and exercise
exercise i don't need to exercise
i take vitamins minerals that's a good
way to say it but if you say the other
way i don't need to take vitamins and
minerals because of exercise you're
going to die 50 years early
okay
and um
okay now i'll give you a quick
thing here back in the days of the
plantations you know a couple hundred
years ago
plantation owners was not unusual for
them to die at age 50.
and these slaves
would live to be a hundred
why was that well they were getting all
the wood ashes they were eating all the
the stuff
the you know the livers the chickens and
the fish and so forth and eating the
bones and making bone broth and
everything the plantation owners were
just eating meat and drinking red wine
and so the the slaves
lived
almost double the lifespan of the
plantation owners
all right thank you very much dr walek
we're out of time now
i want to thank
you doc for being here and for all of
our participants for showing up and all
the people that are listening to
askdoclive.com
and watching it in their homes
on the replay
i want to also thank my wonderful
co-host nasima omar and jonty mccollier
who keeps he keeps everything running in
the background and nasima is texting and
chatting with everybody
also i want to thank rebecca dukes kozak
and askdoc live for making this show
possible
and
we'll see you all next week thank you
for coming and um have a great weekend
okay thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you
ruth ellen thank you thank you to sema
thank you john t and even at a distance
thank you so much rebecca
god bless everybody it was a great great
show today
we talked to a lot of people and they
will share the message don't forget
the new book set
the truth about nutrition the book the
cd and the dvd and remember if you get
10 sets we'll take 10 off of each set
and it'll save 100 bucks
okay god bless and see you next week
bye doc thank you
bye-bye